to jab or not to jab a question parents
have been asking for years now
finally answered by the nhs who say from
monday the vaccine will be available for
5 to 11 year olds
but do parents want their kids to get
the vaccine no i will not be
i think that vaccinations are not enough
tested maybe not on monday but i will do
it i will die definitely i've had covid
but she didn't get catch it and we live
in the same house i know so
i don't think they need it
clearly some parents are still hesitant
and experts are keen to reassure them
this vaccine has been tried and tested
on many five to 11 year olds in other
countries and we've got very good
evidence that it is safe for children if
you look at the wider activities of a
child going to school
going to parties
meeting relatives who might be older or
vulnerable and not been able to i think
having a coveted vaccine enables all of
these other things that are so important
to our young children and while serious
illness in children as a result of covid
is rare it's not unheard of
and those suffering have been calling on
the government for more support like
scott who says life for their family
changed after testing positive my
daughter was um
you know going to school uh full time
she did
ballet
aerial hoop
you know loads of activities physically
active friendship groups and that sort
of stuff
and now you know she can't manage a
school a full school day at all if we'd
had the option to have our daughter
vaccinated before and it would have
prevented her conditions now
then yes we would have taken that
opportunity
the nhs says it's already jab children
who have medical conditions that put
them at risk and data shows it's safe
but it seems that when it comes to
healthy children many adults may still
need some convincing shaman freeman
powell sky news